et on va recevoir Gill kpel alors c'est
vraiment c'est c'est un honneur he pour
nous de le recevoir ce soir prophète en
son pays bien sûr son livre actuellement
aux éditions l'Observatoire c'est
vraiment une des références actuell he
Gill kel vous avez vu il est toujours
cité d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'on
reçoit un spécialiste du du du Proche
Orient et il est avec nous ce soir on va
faire le point bien entendu sur ce qui
se passe au Proche Orient les
bombardement ce sont intensifié à Gaza
un aéroport a été pris d'ASS après
l'atterrissage d'un vol venant de Tel
Aviv aussi vous l'avez vu en Russie ça
c'est incroyable incroyable incroyable
vous allez voir ces images c'est
complètement fou on a envie de faire le
point avec G K et qui nous explique bien
entendu tout cela mais avant tout
regardez ces terribles images de
bombardement de ce weekend à
gazae
[Musique]
merci Gill Capel d'être avec nous en
direct à 19h51 nen touche pas pass c'est
vraiment c'est important pour nous de
nous avoir beaucoup de gens vous citent
en plus à chaque fois qu'il y a des
person personnes qui viennent sur ce
plateau elle vous cite on rappelle votre
livre un prophète en son pays aux
éditions de l'Observatoire ça c'est
vraiment un ouvrage qu'il faut l
absolument je vous le dis pour tous ceux
qui nous regardent même les plus les
plus jeunes est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire déjà ce qui s'est passé ce weekend
à Gaza B là on a vu maintenant le début
d'une offensive ou de la contreoffensive
israélienne puisque pour les dirigeants
de l'État d'Israël après la catastrophe
à la fois humaine politique et militaire
qui a été la radia du 7 octobre avec ces
1400 personnes au moins d'après ce qu'on
sait qui ont été massacrées et les
images ont circulé sur l'ensemble des
réseaux sociaux donc les autorités
israéliennes ont décidé de mener une
contreoffensive en disant que leur
objectif était d'éradiquer le mouvement
terroriste Hamas je les cite à qui on
impute la responsabilité des assassinats
du 7 octobre mais bien évidemment cette
offensive dans un territoire extrêmement
peuplé tout petit ne peut pe pas se
produire sans accompagne sans
s'accompagner de d'un grand nombre de
victimes euh bien sûr selon les
autorités israéliennes les militants les
activistes les dirigeants du Hamas mais
aussi une grande partie de la population
civile qui n'a pas soit voulu fuir soit
pu fuir et l'une des grandes différences
entre ce qui s'est passé le 7 octobre et
ce qui se passe en ce moment c'est que
on a disposé des images C espèces
d'images atroces obsèes même des réseaux
sociaux qui ont sont allés dans le monde
entier où on a vu des gens qui se
faisaient tuer égorger et cetera et
encore en France on a vu dans les pays
occidentaux des images généralement
flouté ailleurs quand on regardait les
réseaux sociaux dans le reste du monde
c'était des images absolument atroces
sanguidonnantes épouvantables mais là
précisément parce qu'il y a le blackard
de l'information sur Gaza parce que euh
le l'Internet et tout l'électricité ont
été coupé on ne voit pas ce qui se passe
on a des images celles que celles que
vous avez à l'écran c'est-à-dire qui
sont fournis par la télévision
israélienne on voit les les chars qui
sont en train d'avancer mais on ne voit
pas
l'intensité des morts et pour ça on
dépend principalement de la
l'information fournie par les les
dirigeants du Hamas alors on a vu on a
vu sur les réseaux sociaux des des
images terribles moi j'ai deux exemples
qui m'ont frappé il y a cet exemple il y
a cette image C cette scène qui tourne
beaucoup les personnes du Hamas viennent
chercher vienent vient viennent dans
uneun famille vont chercher un des fils
de la famille lui disent d'aller taper
chez le voisin ils exterminent la
famille voisin puis le le fils et puis
il y a aussi cette image aussi qu'on a
vu à Gaza alors qu'elle est cent on a vu
ce ce petit garçon à Gaza qui va
reconnaître les cadavres de toute sa
famille oui ça c'est c'est deux images
moi qui m'ont vraiment ce weekend
vraiment bouleversé et c'est vrai que ça
c'est des images c'est les deux images
qui ont le plus tourné sur les réseaux
ce petit que ce soit ce petit garçon ou
ce jeune homme qui va taper à la porte
des voisins et voilà pour qu'après se
fasse massacrer c'est c'est c'est fou ça
c'est aussi cette guerre des réseaux
sociaux euh aujourd'hui euh on a
l'impression je je vous dire ce qui est
fou c'est que je reçois beaucoup de SMS
de des deux côtés et c'est fou de dire
aussi des deux côtés parce qu'il y a des
gens qui me disent oui c'est aussi une
guerre de la communication et ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est ce qu'on voit aussi
actuellement oui tout à fait parce que
chacun d'une certaine manière a tendance
à s'identifier avec les siensou et euh
un camp dit c'est atroce parce que ce
sont des juifs qui ont été tués ce sont
des Occidentaux qui ont été tués d'une
manière barbare on s'identifie à ses
victimes et on considère que leurs
assassins sont des meurtriers et
d'autres disent ce sont des Arabes et
des Palestiniens des musulmans qui ont
été tués c'est la faute des Israéliens
c'est la faute des Occidentaux qui les
ont soutenus et par exemple ça a été le
thème du grand discours d'Erdogan à
l'aéroport d'Istanbul aujourd'hui
accusant l'Occident la croix de de de
lutter contre le croissant et cetera re
insensible devant ces deux images qu'on
soit de de voilà qu'on soit israélien ou
palestinien on peut pas être insensible
devant devant C ces images que je vous
ai décrite que j'ai pas voulu moner oui
c'est un peu pour ça si je peux dire
pour ça c'est un peu le sens je crois de
la du voyage du président Macron dans la
région qui était un voyage qui
recherchait d'une certaine manière à
voir toutes les parties
pour favoriser un dialogue un processus
de paix si c'est encore on peut encore
dire ça aujourd'hui mais c'était aussi
un voyage qui était destiné à la
population française puisque vous savez
que la France est le pays d'Europe où il
y a la plus importante population
d'origine ou de confession juive sur le
territoire français de citoyens français
ou résident citoyens pour l'essentiel et
également la plus importante population
d'origine musulmane ou de confession
musulmane et donc c'était aussi une
volonté d'apaiser les choses et de faire
en sorte d'éviter l'identification si ce
n'est au aux victimes puisqueaprès tout
on a on s'identifie à toutes les
victimes c'est ce que vous êtes en train
de dire en tout cas de traduire ça dans
la haine face à ceux du camp opposé et
c'est bien c'est bien le c'est bien l'un
des grands enjeux aujourd'hui et l'une
des grandes inquiétudes à l'intérieur de
nos société ici en France et ailleurs
l'assassinat du professeur Dominique
Bernard à haras n'était pas causé
directement par ce qui s'est passé à à
Gaza c'est ce que j'ai appelé le
djihadisme d'atmosphère c'est
c'est-à-dire que ça crée une ambiance
dans lequel quelqu'un qui avait déjà
envie de passer à l'acte tout d'un coup
c'est dans c'est senti d'autant plus
motivé à le faire voyez et ça c'est un
véritable enjeu c'est très très complié
c'est pour pour ça que c'est très
important je crois qu'une une émission
comme la vutre qui a un très grand un
très grand rayonnement puisse justement
contribuer à essayer de mettre les
choses à plat autant que possible en
tout cas dans notre société bien
évidemment c'est pas ici sur votre
plateau qu'on va faire la paix au
Moyen-Orient mais si on peut éviter
l'exacerbation des patients je crois que
on aura fait une re utile ex ce qui est
fou Gill kppel c'est que on le voit sur
les réseaux sociaux on peut pas une
personne ne peut pas condamner les deux
scènes que je vous ai décrit tout à
l'heure c'est-à-dire qu'on a
l'impression qu'il faut condamner ou
l'une ou l'autre alors que ces deux
scènes sont insoutenables les l'une et
l'autre et c'est vrai qu'on le voit
aujourd'hui voilà c'est on peut pas
aujourd'hui voilà se dire voilà je je
c'est inadmissible ce que j'ai vu là et
c'est inadmissible ce que j'ai vu là ça
c'est c'est bien le problème des réseaux
sociaux c'est que dans les réseaux
sociaux vous adhérez à un groupe qui est
le vôtre et donc c'est pas du tout
quelque chose où on essaie généralement
de de déterminer le vrai et le faux ou
de faire la part des choses mais au
contraire on adhère à un groupe et les
les adhérants à ce groupe se montrent
les uns et les autres si vous voulez et
euh vous allez plutôt vers le réseaux
sociaux dont vous pensez qu'il va
réfléchir vos propres fantasmes vos
propres fureurs et cetera et c'est toute
la difficulté parce que une émission
comme la vôtre si euh les gens disent
des bêtises ou incriminent tel ou tel
ils sont ensuite ils peuvent être
poursuivis en justice il y a eu des dans
les réseaux sociaux c'est le vous êtes
anonyme vous êtes protégé par votre
anonymat et euh c'est en particulier
pour la les gens plus jeunes que nous
ici qui se nourrissent principalement de
ça c'est un c'est un enjeu absolument
fondamental alors euh je je j'ai une
question à vous poser Gill c'est une
question que tout le monde me pose
actuellement c'est
euh éradiquer le Hamas aujourd'hui on
l'a vu avec daesh à l'époque euh on
entendait on veut éradiquer daesh c'est
impossible qu' il y a tout de suite
d'autres mouvements il y a l'état
islamique qui est venu après voilà et
cetera est-ce que c'est possible
aujourd'hui
euh de de de de de se dire aujourd'hui
on va éradiquer le Hamas alors c'est une
question très importante si pour ceux
que ça intéresse dans ce livre justement
je raconte précisément comment le
djihadisme a muté si vous voulez comment
on est passé du djihad en Afghanistan
ensuite du djihad qu'on a vu en Algérie
en Égypte l'Algérie qui avait frappé la
France dans les années 90 puis à
Al-Qaïda qui a frappé l'ennemi lointain
aux États-Unis ensuite au djihad en
réseau de daesh avec des gens qui
circulaient pour l'essentiel entre le
Levant c'est-à-dire la Syrie l'Irak et
puis l'Europe notamment la France et
toutes ces organisations d'E une
certaine manière ont finit par être
liquidé parce que c'était des
organisations qui n'avaient pas de base
dans la masse de la société si vous
voulez qui étaent des groupes
extrêmement restreints qui donnai des
ordres mais qui n'étaient pas implantés
le Hamas c'est assez différent parce que
c'est au départ une organisation qui
s'est construite parmi les Palestiniens
c'est pas quelque chose qui est venu
d'en haut une organisation assez
complexe qui a d'ailleurs dans il faut
le dire dans un certain nombre de cas
était favorisé et c'est le paradoxe par
les autorités israéliennes elles-mêmes
et notamment par Monsieur netanahou le
Premier Ministre actu justement parce
que pour nos téléspectateurs euh je dis
ils ont entendu de nombreux intervenants
dire ici le Hamas a été créé par
netanielou est-ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ça cré non pas créer
exactement c'est ça parce que c'est ce
c'est ce qui a été dit ici donc est-ce
que vous pouvez expliquer vraiment le
vrai du faux de cou enfin je vais
essayer après on peut aussi ne pas être
d'accord avec mes explications bien sûr
mais euh quand il y a eu le processus de
paix le processus d'Oslo entre Israël et
les Palestiniens il y a eu dans chez
certains dirigeants israéliens la
volonté de favoriser l'émergence de
mouvements islamiques face à l'OLP qui
était nationaliste et moi je me souviens
par exemple quand je faisais ma thèse en
Égypte en 1980 quand le l'Égypte avait
récupéré le Sinaï je suis allé dans le
Sinaï et en traversant le canal on
attendait à l'époque il y avait pas
tellement de sécurité où il y avait le
chargé d'affaires israélien qui
attendait aussi j'ai un peu discuté avec
lui et sa femme qui était une juif
française et il m'a demandé sur quoi je
travaillais je faisais ma thèse sur les
frères musulm il m'a dit ah ça
m'intéresse ça nous intéresse beaucoup
puisque les Frères musulmans sont des
gens avec lesquels il faudra qu'on
travaille également voyez et donc il y
avait toujours cette volonté de d'une
certaine manière de euh faire en sorte
que à l'intérieur de la Palestine les
mouvements religieux soient aussi
présents pour diminuer l'influence des
mouvements nationalistes vous voyez pour
affaiblir leur leur adversaire pour
qu'il y ait plusieurs interlocuteurs qui
du reste étaient se battaaient entre eux
ou étaient hostiles les uns aux autres
ensuite ce qui s'est passé dans lesf
récente et pendant les les gouvernements
netaniaahou c'est que puisque Gaza il
faut bien se rendre compte Gaza est une
cocote minute en explosion permanente
avec une population qui est venue
généralement voyez de on voit sur votre
carte d'une grande partie des
territoires qui sont devenus Israël qui
n'ont pas où aller où les gens vivent en
grande partie des subventions qui sont
fournies par les par les Nations-Unies
et donc il fallait trouver une solution
pour assurer la vie quotidienne et le
Qatar chaque chaque mois envoyait un
avion plein de dollars qui arrivait à
l'aéroport benouron qui était escorté
par les services secrets israéliens le
Mossad le shinbet jusqu'à Erz
c'està-dire jusqu'à la fron cette
fameuse barrière électronique moi que
j'ai traversé de nombreuses fois quand
j'allais en
en dans la bande de Gaza ou ailleurs
pour pour faire mes mes enquêtes et mes
études et qui était quelque chose qui
apparaissait comme complètement
infranchissable si vous voulez ce qui
pose des questions sur la manière dont
elle a pu être désactivée avec une telle
facilité et je ne pense pas que ce soit
un garagiste du Hamas avec un tournevis
et une clé à molette qui a fait ça on a
là à mon sens l'action de service
étatique beaucoup plus important
c'est-à-dire celui qui aujourd'hui est
derrière le Hamas et en fait le Ferd LAN
ce qu'on appelle son axe la résistance
c'est-à-dire les Gardiens de la
révolution iranienne et donc vous aviez
ensuite les services secrets égyptiens
qui escortaient dans la partie Gaza les
les dollars du du Qatar qui était
réparti pour payer les fonctionnaires
les hôpitaux et cetera mais évidemment
le Hamas prenait euh sa ses frait de
dossier si j'ose dire important et donc
vous aviez cet espèce de de Modus
vivindi et c'est aujourd'hui quelque
chose qui est qui est fait l'objet d'une
remise en cause très profonde en Israël
et néaniaou est accusé pour cette pour
cette raisonlà il faut bien voir aussi
que le processus de paix qui les que les
Américains ont ont favorisé entre un
certain nombre de gouvernements arabes
et le et les Israéliens par exemple le
Maroc le les Émirats arabes unis Bahrein
autes avant il y avait la l'Égypte et la
Jordanie avait pour objectif pourquoi
est-ce que ces gouvernements ce C
souhaitait pactiser avec avec Israël
c'est aussi pour disposer de de
l'armement israélien qui leur permettait
de s'opposer à leurs adversaires le
Maroc à l'Algérie le les Émirats à
l'Iran par par exemple et donc tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui
entre en ligne de compte pour répondre à
votre première question à savoir
pourquoi est-ce qu'il c'est ça un tel
déchaînement de violence parce que dans
terme de géopolitique régionale et
mondiale Israël a besoin de restaurer
l'image de sa supériorité militaire
voire de son invincibilité qui a été
très profondément mise à mal par la
facilité déconcertante avec laquelle la
frontière a été désactivée des gens sont
passés à travers alors vous savez qu'il
y a aujourd'hui toutes sortes de débats
très importants en Israël accusant
justement netania o d'avoir disons érodé
la la fibre nationale israélienne en
s'appuyant sur l'extrême droite des
colons en sisjordanie qui lui permettait
de changer la Constitution pour qu'il
n'aille pas en prison pour ce dont il
est accusé et cetera ça s'est traduit
par le fait qu'un certain nombre de
pilotes israéliens de l'élite militaire
et cetera ont refusé de faire leur
période et puis une grande partie de
l'armée était envoyé en sis-jordanie euh
si on revoit la carte comme ça les gens
la verront voilà c'est ça voyez là où il
y a écrit Jérusalem la bande de Gaza est
en bas c'est tout petit ce j'en est
beaucoup plus grand pour soutenir les
colons et faire la police dans les
colonistes qui a complètement dégarni la
bande tout ça ça fait partie aujourd'hui
des des des remises en cause qui se
produisent en Israël et qui font que
monsieur netaniaou est extrêmement
critiqué au moment même où il il lance
l'offensive alors l'offensive elle se
produit comment elle se produit euh au
départ il y a eu tout un des
déclarations qui disait on va attaquer
on va tout détruire on va éradiquer le
Hamas mais en réalité ça ça se passe de
manière progressive je dire ce qui
n'enlève rien à la à la à l'étendue des
dégâts à l'étendue des victimes et
cetera avec chaque fois la possibilité
de faire un pas pour la négociation de
l'autre côté qu'est-ce qu'il y a en face
d'Israël il n'y a pas seulement le Hamas
il y a aussi ceux qui font les
intermédiaires c'est-à-dire le Qatar le
pays sur lequel s'était appuyé monsieur
netaniaahou justement pour gérer Hamas
d'une manière indirecte et puis derrière
parce que la plupart des dirigeants de
Hamas vivent au les grands dirigeants le
plus fameux vivent aujourd'hui au Qatar
dans les grands hôtels à Dra et il y a
l'Iran derrière qui voit dans le Hamas
si vous voulez le fer de lance de la
ligne de résistance contre Israël qui
l'a mise en place avec le Hezbollah
libanais et cetera la différence c'est
que Hamas est un parti sunite issu des
Frères musulmans alors que tous les
autres sont des partis chiit qui donc
sont deux versions différentes de
l'islam et il y a une espèce de lutte
aujourd'hui à l'occasion de cette guerre
pour l'hégémonie sur l'islam politique
entre d'un côté le pôle iranien dirigé
par l'Iran et s Garn la Révolution et de
l'autre côté un monde sunnit dont les
principales organisations politiques ont
été très affaiblies ces derniers temps
daesh a été
ratatiné kaaïda détruite et les Frères
musulmans eux-mêmes sont en position de
faiblesse donc si vous voulez c'est tout
ce tout ça se joue joue en même temps et
c'est ça qui rend le décryptage du
phénomène un peu trop un peu complexe
j'espère que j'aié à vous comprendre et
non pas à rendre les choses difficiles
mais Gill Kepel moi je parlis avec mon
ami la ma coiffeuse il y a un instant
m'a dit de toute façon je peux mal te
coiffer parce que il va on va tous on va
tous y passer il va y avoir une trème
guerre mondiale 4e comme on dit
qu'est-ce que vous dites qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça aujourd'hui mais je
crois qu'il y a un un très grand
sentiment d'inquiétude aujourd'hui euh
sur l'embrasement h euh parce qu'on voit
bien que par exemple voyez le euh des
alliés de l'Iran qui sont les Houtis du
Yémen du Nord ont envoyé des missiles
euh sur le golfe d'Akaba ou d'ilat qui
sont tombés sur l'Égypte qui auraient pu
toucher des bateaux civil qui se
trouvaient là et euh donc on est aussi
dans une situation où il n'y a plus
véritablement le système des grandes
alliance autrefois qui d'une certaine
manière maintenait l'ordre c'est-à-dire
vous aviez le bloc occidental avec
l'OTAN le bloc du PACT de Varsovie il y
avait des conflits localisés et du reste
c'est dans le monde musulman que tout ça
a commencé à se déglinguer puisque c'est
le djihad en Afghanistan qui a fait
tomber l'Armée rouge et qui a exposé que
c'était plus qu'un un tigre de papier
qui fait que l'URSS s'est effondré avec
la chute du Mur de Barlin en 1989 mais
aujourd'hui on a plus ça on a plus ces
ces ces blocs qui s'appuient les uns sur
les autres et on voit bien qu'on a
plusieurs lignes de faill font il y a la
guerre en Ukraine il y a la guerre qui
renait au Moyen-Orient il y a
l'affrontement américain avec la Chine
et donc tout ça s'interpénètre et les
vous n'avez plus comme autrefois les
États-Unis ou euh l'Union soviétique qui
donne des ordres à des alliés alors
c'est là toute la difficulté parce que
au Moyen-Orient chacun d'une certaine
manière joue sa carte essae de de de
pousser son avantage mais on n'est plus
dans une situation qui est contrôlée
comme autrefois vous comprenez